that brings up willie adamus
young leader of the raise
sharply hit and that's by ruiz up the
left field line
adamus digging for two and he's in there
with a double
with two outs a scoring opportunity yeah
you know this is a
another example of the raise two outs
nobody on and they continue to press you
and this was one of those change-ups
that willia thomas is able to keep fair
and get by right there and with that the
rays have this opportunity for
yoshi satsugo here it comes and yoshi
lists one of the air into left center
field giving chase austin hayes
banger the warning track gets up against
the wall he reaches back for the karen
madoma's around third and scores easily
yoshida second he pulls in with a two
strike two out double
and the rays take a one-nothing lead in
baltimore lakes now back to the mound at
the bottom of the second inning
and leftion lefty here to rio ruiz so
three and two to count
fastball swingled and missed strike
three 96 slightly elevated down goes rio
ruiz instead had veleka
batting right handed two balls two
strikes the left-hander
to the plate curves swung on and missed
three two out and
nobody on in the second dj stuart lefty
on left
swinging a mess he struck him out a
fastball that got into zanino's glove
might have nicked the handle of the bat
and blake snell
strikes out the side for the first time
2020.
now adam is at second two outs in the
third for renfrow
fly ball into right field sending
santander back
that's going to be high off the wall the
run will
score renfro into second with a double
the opposite way
and with two outs the raids score their
second round of the game
here's this sinker working its way back
towards the middle of the plate this one
is down but renfro
with good lift powerful the other way
another two out run
and they leave this tune up oreo fourth
inning it'll be nunez santander
and severino against blake snell
and this one's lined base hit to left
field
it will be cut off by tutsugo but nunez
will stroll into second base with a
double to lead off the bottom of the
fourth inning
so a good setup for santander santander
struck out his first at-bat
fly ball well hit deep center field here
meyer back back back
and can't get it it's out of here for a
two-run homer
we've seen pierre meyer catch a lot of
those not this time
santander with a two-run shot to tie the
game
oh how fast it can change looked like
blake snell and the rays were on cruise
control but anthony suntan
there and now pedro severino will dig in
and this one's crushed pierre meyer
going back to center field again still
going back looking up
and that is gone back-to-back home runs
for the orioles
and they have taken the lead in the
fourth inning
well the boom sticks are out here at the
bottom of the fourth inning and blake
snell can't believe it but the orioles
are starting to catch
up to that fastball and we talked about
can they make some adjustments
the second time through the lineup well
guess what the orals have made some
adjustments and that's going to be it
for blake snell orioles have knocked him
right out of the game back-to-back jacks
from santander
and severino orioles on top 3-2
pitching change at camden yards two
balls in the strike
the shortstop andrew velasquez
center field and it's hit well kiermeier
racing back does he have room
he makes the catch and slams into the
wall
that's the guy that has three gold
gloves he had the home run go off his
glove
not this time nice running catch toronto
brandon lowell williams and yoshi
tsutsugo
the pitch is a swing and a high drive
deep towards the right field corner
santander looking up on the wall
and it is off the top of the wall
lao heads for second and he'll pull in
there with a double
wondering if it was a home run of course
from where we are on the monitor we
can't see the first base umpire
see if he made any sort of ruling for
now it's a double for lao
kevin cash is coming out of the third
base dugout and saying was that over the
wall and off the railing
and they're getting together with paul
nart and i think they're going over the
ground rules right now
that was definitely over the out of town
scoreboard the question is does it have
to clear the wall and hit
a social security advertisement out
there
rattled off of that well above the wall
but does it have to clear that
to be a home run and i guess the answer
is no it's all he has to do is throw the
wall
yeah so it's a home run for brandon lau
his first
of 2020 and he's just like that has tied
the game at three
well left on left you're thinking maybe
advantage paul
frye not so much second strikeout for
fairbanks and that'll bring up
alberto hit on the ground sharply at
third
diaz goes to the line picks throws to
first doesn't get much on it
and choi has to come down the line it's
an infield single for alberto
toward alberto running swinging a miss
throw to second
and he got in beat the throw so stolen
base
[Applause]
for hansar alberto average maybe a
little bit above average speed he takes
off gets a good jump and there's a swing
by nunez trying to hit it to the right
side hit behind the runner but alberto
with too good of a jump and he picks
up only the second stolen base of the
year so far for the orioles
and tandir with two rbis has an
opportunity here to give the orioles the
lead
first pitch center field clear meyer
coming hard
won't get it it falls in base hit
alberto scores and the orioles have the
lead
base is loaded rio ruiz the batter
rio short roller they're going to come
to the plate choy high throw
safe the throw pulled zanino
in the air zanino points to the dugout
and says let's challenge this thing
and here's the tail he's safe he's in
yeah i believe he's in there
417 on the season for hancer alberto
breaking ball hit well way back deep
left field and this ball is gone
for the second straight game hotzer
alberto goes yard
and the orioles add another run
and now leave it 6-3